alors on est là pour annoncer un
ensemble un stop c'est que sa fuite est
aujourd'hui dans l'après midi très bien
très peu mais avec en plus construit
c'était ce matin on s'est appelé on
s'est dit c'est bizarre ça n'a pas futé
est là cet après midi s'affûter puisque
christophe vous avez appelé par tous ben
non moi je sais pas moi j'aurais préféré
le dire moi tu vois pas d'issue
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire je vais
dire que voilà que tu dis habite à la
maison pas plus de deux semaines vous ai
pas peur de ça mais bon c'est ouvert et
aborde d'abord ce que des bisous puis on
verra après exactement christophe qui va
animer à prendre ou à laisser à partir
de lundi fini le premier l'a dit je suis
très content alors christophe lapointe
il ya plein de gens qui nous disent
voilà si j'aime bien je joue pas ah bah
non non le jeu à mon honneur parce que
tu t'y vous fait tu passé on rencontre
que je vais me faire 25 nouveaux copains
ouais c'est ça 24 peut-être et 1/2 le
banquier à ça j'ai hâte de la voir en
ligne non c'est un jeu c'est un jeu très
très sabbatique et qu'il est ce qu'il
est vraiment de la place pour un pour
être avec les gens donc comme c'est ce
que j'aime faire et c'est cool non non
je suis très content merci donc aux
hommes d'aller je regarde les séries
anciens d'ailleurs c'était l'occasion
d'une à l'occasion je me suis endormi
mais qui était toc mais il était tard
parce que thorgal j'ai du mal à achever
pas très patient donc je regarde
beaucoup d'épisodes a cité à cinq heures
du matin je pique du nez et il se trouve
que j'étais très confortablement
installé devant une série que j'adore
qui s'appelle aux autres et vous l'avez
vu oui non oui la crémaillère limite
heures par jour comment vais-je me donne
déjà des trucs huit heures par jour
[Rires]
j'ai regardé la nuit je me suis
réveillée parce que j'étais torse nu que
ma fenêtre était entrouverte et que
j'étais à la campagne et qu'en fait je
me suis je fais la crème brûlée par le
froid et j'ai envoyé un texto à 10 ans
dites-moi merrill et les boîtes dont on
avait parlé alors et puis voilà à
saint-herblain à 6h30 du matin
mais non là c'est ça si longue mais j'ai
aussi regardé par 1 ouais je suis très
contente et stocks parce que j'ai
toujours dit si tu étais tu es voilà si
tu sais que j'étais a été inventé un
modèle pour moi donc vraiment très très
heureux que tu intègres la chaîne j'ai
toujours dit voilà je me suis devenu un
jeu rapide et requiert deux mois c'est
pour ta vu qu est ce n'était pas joli à
voir
c'est pour ça que tu m'a appelé vraiment
à 6h du matin il doit être encore connue
je vais l'appeler normes et christophe
va démarrer donc à prendre ou à laisser
il n'est pas que marc burg les questions
posées à christophe willem dont six
mètres voilà dans l'équipe voilà c'est
gilles fait le monde la terre c'est
chanter je vous adore enchanté de votre
tour sa mère était avec moi non c'est
oui exactement
c'est merveilleux vous soyez de retour à
prendre ou à laisser moi je suis fan du
jeu j'ai un tout petit peu de mal avec
les règles que je trouve complexe est ce
que vous pourriez m'expliquer les règles
du jeu et vous pouvez me les expliquez
vous voulez je vous fasse le déroulé de
toutes les carrières pas question
revient mais on nouveau des boîtes
j'ai un candidat bernard à côté de moi
qui ai une boîte dont il ne connaît pas
le montant
moi non plus après il ya que le banquier
qui connaît le montant
peut-être peut-être patron d'être le
patron et il doit éliminer un maximum de
boîte pour avoir la plus grosse et
partir avec une très grosse somme dans
la la ça paraît assez simple
après écrit christophe tu es heureux un
bon terreau de le faire sachant très
heureux en vrai alors il ya exactement
ce que j'aime mon métier d'une pas trop
sexe et ça a fait un petit jeu vous dire
je ne sais pas si c'est comme le vélo ça
fait un petit moment je n'ai pas pris tu
vas était donc je sers un petit peu les
fesses parce que je ne sais pas si je
veux savoir le frère est stressé doit
forcément je déboule
fait non non non non s'ils voulaient
travailler avec joe à ce que tu dis que
j'adore il souvent ni ta vie tu dis j'ai
envie de faire mon métier
moi ça me fait kiffer c'est vrai mais
web ici c'est mon métier
ouais mais si c'est oui vraiment moi
j'adore christophe dechavanne parce que
je venais vraiment beaucoup je voulais
je vais voir à coucou c'est nous à la
place à nez avec les potes ont débarqué
chez moi je suis pour que toutes les
émissions plus de 50 émissions vous avez
présenté à toute période de l'année de
la télé qu'à évoluer les réseaux sociaux
vous avez vu tout arriver quelle période
vous prive vous avez préféré quelle
période s'acquitter pourquoi c'est super
compliqué parce qu'il ya plein peut être
différente
j'ai adoré quand j a participé
partiellement mardi parce que c'était
donner la parole à des gens qui n'y
avaient pas accès en tout cas à la
télévision donc j'ai reçu des milliers
d'invités pour parler aussi bien les
dames pipi que des banquiers qui porte
des bas dans que de l'excision que des
choses graves lourde
hénin on rigolait beaucoup à la fin avec
un bloc notes pour que les gens il se
couchait avec le sourire on vient chez
moi je suis tombé sur des feuilles
d'audience arrivé un petit peu moins de
chaînes mais on faisait 75 78 %
d'audience à minuit avec 7 millions de
personnes c'est un trio fin mai mais je
peux pas après coucou c'est nous je me
suis éclaté c'est encore mieux mais
c'était mes débuts je me suis éclatée du
fer dans les épinards c'était un forum
où tout le monde avait la parole j'ai
adoré franchement yacine et c'est très
difficile puisque j'ai préféré ou de
tester tête tf1 ils tuent les a prévenus
que tu allais faire peuvent eux non
enfin ben barbaud non puisque il fallait
pas paniquer pas de fuite
adacore démissionner
[Applaudissements]
christophe est ce que tu es ce que avec
qui j'ai travaillé
la chance du grand ensemble c'était
super est-ce que tu y croyait tu n'y
croyait plus parce que je t'ai entendu
les dernières d'une interview tu disais
on disait tu disais on veut enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'on veut plus de moi j'ai
pas dit ça je peux je souhaitais c'était
un peu comme si c'était ma mère odieuse
voulait pas vraiment de moi parce que
sinon ils ont mon téléphone
en revanche je disais que je me donnais
encore là ça va faire six mois donc je
me donne encore deux ans et demi je me
donnais trois ans et au bout de trois
ans si vraiment je faisais pas d'antenne
si je faisais pas mon job
si je leur faisais parce que j'aime oui
il avait fallu également donné je je je
m'assois dessus une dernière fois pour
arrêter d'être dans l'espoir elle
attendre voilà alors il ya des gens
aussi culotte pourquoi je n'ai pas
continué à prendre ou à laisser
à cause de moi voilà la photo que ça
mais je vous lis pas ce qu'on va
préparer déjà la saison prochaine et que
vous le savez je pense non mais moi je
raconte pas d'histoires ya l'euro à
partir du dimanche raconte sa mère et
j'ai dit assez vite à partir du 10 juin
vont m'oublier
non mais c'est vrai j'avais oublié voilà
parce que vous les regardez l'euro non
mais franchement je t'aime en main pour
garder l'euro meet équipe en valeur et
je t'inviterai la maison après mais je
vous lis et je dis la vérité et en plus
on sera de retour pour une nouvelle
saison
on va on va travailler mais vous revenez
après là prêts à prendre ou à laisser
mais pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
voire plus - terminé aux acteurs non
mais bon oui bâche qui va préparer la
saison prochaine personne mais oui bah
oui bah voilà oui alors oui tiffany oui
vous avez dit monsieur njawe à nouveau
genre si c était le parent ici et c'est
vrai mais vous êtes aussi un patron vous
êtes employé donc sur le long terme
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut
fonctionner de ce choc des titans sur la
chaîne sur la choc des titans non mais
est ce que est ce que m'a regardé je
suis désolé en bande annonce a fait la
gaffe c'est parti donc je me dis est ce
que vous pensez que ça peut durer avec
mes jeux jeux patron comme ça mais pour
l'aisne pour le pour l'instant je viens
faire quinze jours donc je me pose pas
la question
c'est juste m by step j'ai intérêt avec
ce que je vis depuis trois ans vraiment
pas depuis trois ans depuis 20 ans et je
dis que christophe on se parle beaucoup
enfin ce petit mot christophe et moi on
se connaît et franchement je le connais
maintenant je sais qu'il est comme moi
et voilà ça descend pas tout pas tout de
suite quand même un peu bon tu vois donc
c'est vrai et on se prend pas la tête
tous les deux prochains mois on se prend
pas la tête
christophe et moi on s'en fout on peut
dire un truc voilà on n'est pas intérêt
tu trouves pas
on est où faut que je réfléchisse
découlent ah ça on écoule oui j'en ai
dois je suis cool mais pourquoi
réfléchissent oui aux dernières
questions parce qu'on va partir
christophe d'appeler stop pour toi c'est
une remise en selle un peu c'est à une
remontée à cheval comme on dit succès
avec une selle oui et est ce que dans
ton idée ça va marcher forcément l'idée
est ce qu'à la rentrée tu espères rester
sur ces vite non mais je suis face alors
ému le premier bar gay regardez moi je
te regarde pas
4 le patron c'est cyril est ce qui t'a
laissé entendre que peut-être y aurait
d'autres étudiants suivant c'est une
course rateront c'est vraiment capitaux
oui mais en fait on glane nord
christophe et il était on a les noms
mais pas facile vous avez du pouvoir
aussi quand j'aurai vrai qu'ils
reviennent parce que vous êtes les deux
là je vous ai tous les deux je suis
content je comme un gosse parce que lui
il a commencé à faire des émissions en
direct ou écouter le bordel sur les
vertes avec des dromadaires avec des
chemins odesia d'efforts et casser le
conducteur il nous promettait des choses
qui arrivent et jamais un peu comme vous
il faisait des sketches et c'est vrai et
c'est vrai c'est vrai que vous
maintenant ils servent un coucou c'est
nous bon là c'est différent parce qu'il
ya les regarder il ya ma mère et ma mère
qui moment mais c'est alcoa qui mais
c'est grâce à christophe dechavanne que
cyril a fait d'aller ben voilà
voilà pour sa part tout a été
c'est ma mère tu master nom viendra de
mars il sera dans les boîtes si tu peux
lui mettre les 500000 les poteaux nice
et dans les boîtes doivent en tout cas
je suis très heureux tu arriveras
clients dès qu'il ya un ou deux
enregistrés bc je suis très content moi
même de revenir partager ce que j'aime
faire avec tous ceux qui seront là le
plus nombreux possible
évidemment si on s'y voit là bas sera
dès le lundi 14 mars et le lundi car la
vie 14,1 14 merci creed en direct ou
enregistrée au registre et ben voilà
parce que dans les conditions du direct
exactement mais pas passer si jamais
j'ai un petit malaise ou si je fais pipi
dans ma culotte
alors je voudrais qu'on puisse couper
l'eau des recettes enregistrées surtout
pour l'argent
on